[Music]
many young girls look up to you you have
millions and millions of Instagram
followers who inspires you to be a
better person
rupaul is a really big inspiration of
mine Ellen DeGeneres I love I have so
many people that just constantly
inspired me my fans inspired me every
day you know hearing their stories where
they come from what they go through
inspires me so I've you know I have a
lot of people I look up to for different
motions talking about fan bases you get
so many comments on your social media
you go through them I mean I'd like to
read them sometimes I could just
literally just go down and like the ones
that are sweet or sometimes I'll be like
in a mood and I'll see something and be
like whatever but usually it doesn't
really let me like get for me at all we
have to say to fans who are always
commenting about you and Justin Bieber
um I think it's sweet yeah I mean I was
excused Justin fan before he discovered
me so I think it's really awesome that
they're like so supportive and like oh
it's so cute he doesn't friends now and
stuff he's he's great it's awesome that
I get to have somebody who I've
literally looked up to my whole
childhood as
it's like he's on tour right now I think
he's gonna be in like Israel next week
how is the how is he doing he's so
focused and driven and you know he has
his head on straight which is really
important like he said such a good place
in his life right now and I'm you know
I'm just really happy to see how happy
and healthy news any collab to the you
and Haim coming up that you can see
we've made songs together we've made
multiple records together I are they
going to come out I don't know but
there's definitely stuff in the works
so I guess